est si beau un top 6 des jeux de l'année
non j'ai arrêté les jeux vidéo je suis
un adulte maintenant tu vois mais moi
aussi je suis un adulte on va faire un
top 10 non ça marche ok comme tu veux
dit coroner samouraï katana chevalier
château fort aux vikings à cheval à
acheter comme je fais des bd et ce
qu'ils ont déjà perdu donc respire
preuve que même les joueurs sont pas au
bout de leurs peines
audrey un dessin animé est mignon je
sais pas pourquoi j'y joue alors que je
sais que tu perdes hockey au cutter au
tournoi car je suis envoyé sur terre
pour but et ses robots de bâtard avec
mon bandeau sur les yeux c'est compliqué
d'avoir du mal à garder bonne chose que
mon père c'est à poil
ben alors je croyais que tu avais arrêté
les jeux vidéo
bon j'avoue j'ai joué toute l'année est
tombé mais je les voulais quelqu'un
d'aussi non c'est pas le top 10 du bal
est plus à l'aise mais c'est le top 10
des meilleurs jeux 2010 elle émerge 2010
des meilleurs jeux de 2010 le top 100 et
kenseth ça fait exprès mais sur toutes
les touches pas fait exprès chaumont
style et ma coupe de cheveux
mais bon je n'arrive jamais à calais les
coups que je veux beaucoup c'est ce
horizons je suis trop fort discret
invisible things auteurs j'ai pris une
décision ivre-mort tirer des flèches
sont de gros points qui n'osa cariou la
crète alors monde fusio n'y avait pas
donné d âmes des ours à mario et sa
clique mario fiocco japonais ça donne un
jeu magique x 4 resident evil c'est dans
ce bar est pas évident d'être vice prés
famille tombe de sujets auxquels cette
enquête où l'onu ces boyaux et rillettes
trois super mario bros qui s'est fait ma
casquette aubry ferait je me transforme
en truck diverses et variées il faut
vraiment tout les obliger
de plus belgique portail tu as an sur la
même île sa part en gros ce fight
journaux qui paie survivent le strass
est là faut pas craquer on n'a pas
réussi à choisir toi le guen a préféré
un soldat fatou mbaye l'épée flèche
arqués cote de maille la note on hyrule
au ton plus mal mais je crée toujours
l'effort global top 10 des marques puggy
désastre est utile ça nan c'est pas le
top 10 des mecs les plus balèze des plus
beaux moments de malaise énorme mais
c'est le top 10 des meilleurs shows
comme on dit c'est un des meilleurs jeux
de 1000 concerts des meilleurs jeux 2010
m6 débat public désabusé tout ce qu'ils
savent c'est pas le top 10 des mecs est
balèze que pour un malaise à non
piste et je te mets 10 des meilleurs
jeux de mots
c'était meilleur jeu de mai 10h
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]